do you really believe that me as a
Muslim no it's fine it's fine do you
really believe the prophets The
Prophet's grandchildren are slaughtered
and I'm going to be like yeah it wasn't
a big
[Music]
deal
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala righteous people like
Ali was a righteous person Hussein
Hassan righteous people we don't deny
that we deny they were the righteous
people do you get it their death no huh
why why not more mourn their death are
we am I happy about their death am I
okay one second am I happy that Hussein
was killed butcher do you think I enjoy
it I said why not morning no no one
second morning what way morning is not
his day like Valentine's Day Valentine's
Day is not one day let me tell you
something when you say m what do you
mean when I think that what happened to
Hussein and H do you think I smile he's
cheating I don't know I'm I'm going to
ask you again okay okay I'm ask I'm
going to ask you again do you really
believe that me as a Muslim I don't know
no it's fine it's fine do you really
believe the prophets the prophets
grandchildren are slaughtered and I'm
going to be like yeah it wasn't a big
deal one second one second hand on her
hand on her hand on I don't need to do
you f i don't need to no I do it I do it
for that Allah saved them so what I'm
saying is this why do how could you even
think bro that I will be happy of the
prophets I agree how could you say agree
you're noty cuz that's offensive I
didn't say no you're saying how can I
know no I said I I don't I don't know if
you more we have our differences but
this is the Prophet is it the prophet's
grandchildren is it my prophet's
grandchildren your prophet's
grandchildren how can I be happy bro so
why F on one second bro because to me
there is no evidence to suggest that I
have to F from the Quran the enemies C
they no no the
enemies Allah will deal with them but
why F they celebrated no no what they
celebrated hence why some f we don't f i
don't just because they look the
celebration is it from the Sunnah one
second is it celebration from the one
second is it celebration sunah or not be
done but but it's form Innovation to
kill somebody the prophet and celebrate
it make it their celebration is
innovation why also the fast inovation
why
F no no the celebration is evil and B
and also the morning is uh I wouldn't
say it's evil intention is good but it's
B now that's that's a side issue
actually they done it they done it and
may Allah deal with them why no but why
follow Allah will deal with look look
Allah will deal with them saying why do
you follow what they done on because
that's what
whenever I celebrated the prophet's
children died no but you you fast I
fast I F because mam was with the
children of Israel yes so I'm saying why
we fast is different you're thinking we
fast I don't know what you think anyway
let me just let me just do like brothers
and sisters like well I'll be honest I
came here walking the brothers our sh
Brothers wanted to take a picture we
just go into a discussion please don't
turn this into Shia Sunni well I fear
Allah we had a discussion we have a
disagreement but we look like civilized
people like I said to them before to me
anybody that gets an attribute of Allah
and applies it to anyone if he's a Sunni
if he's a Shia if he's AI if he's a Sufi
if he's a salafi I don't care what it is
it is an act of kufur and it's an act of
sh if they knowingly say this person is
the all knowing that's all I said please
in the comment section don't insult each
other don't say Shia are this sunnis are
this it was just a nice discussion and
leave it as that because at the end of
the day there's an ad and slow to
talking I don't see them as my enemy
okay it's as simple as that and that's
all I'm going to leave
that Islam net is establishing a Masid
and a community center if you donate to
build this Masid Allah will insh build a
house for you in Jenna with bricks of
gold and silver every person who prays
in this Masid every child that memorizes
the Quran you will in share in that
reward donate now guys and do not
[Music]
delay